[Applause]
the soul crossed the lane and throws it
down an impressive move from godzilla
kyle gasol finishes with great strength
and
ryan
looks inside finds cassandra count it
looks like he's looking to score good
job of delivering the pass trusting your
receiver pound the soul with those great
hands to catch in the finish
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
outstanding vision talk about the size
the ability to fight for position double
team comes i see you a little more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as well when he was in memphis you never
noticed in l.a he is
hunting
[Applause]
gasol
what a finish from a chance for a
three-point play this is a play that
would make dr jay proud power of the
soul outstanding move in transgender
that's the only thing we're talking
about
behind his back
[Applause]
anderson
that's an answer and i'm not talking
iverson well i tell you if you're going
to go to the rack pal that's the way to
get
brian for the lead misses cassava backs
it in with five tenths of a second
remaining lakers by one it's not about
kobe bryant it's about attacking the
offensive board so pal gasol puts
himself in position to get the easy put
back big time play by powell assault